One of the potential many side effects of my chemotherapy treatment has been brittle bones.
Seems to be true in my case.
I have had two very minor falls with a last beam about four months ago and I broke four ribs each time.
Oh my goodness, I'm so sorry.
Although I am much better, they still haven't really healed as evident by the CT scans.
Ribs are really hard to heal fractured ribs because they're always in motion.
Every time you take a breath, you're into coastal muscles, contract.
And it's very difficult for a bone to heal when it's constantly being tugged on.
Would you recommend supplement wise or diet wise, that might be helpful for healing and strengthening bones.
Also, my wife has similar questions pertaining to age related osteoporosis.
Okay, the only supplement that I recommend now for bone destruction due to the testesis.
Bold healing due to a fracture, bold healing due to osteoporosis is the one supplement called osteo K.
Let me see if I can pull it up here really quick.
Osteo K.
The reason why is that there's just been more research.
The old thought was we just need to take more calcium.
Oh no, well that didn't work.
So we need to take more calcium with vitamin D.
Well, okay, well that didn't work.
Well, what we do, we need to take other complementary nutrients.
Well, none of them are really working to build bone.
This is the osteo K right here.
It's on our website and taking four of those a day.
The secret of this is that it has this certain type of K2, vitamin K2, that's called MK4.
If you look at most of your vitamin D supplements, I'll say vitamin D plus K2, right?
But almost all those that form of K2 is in the form of MK7, which is great.
MK7 is great to help you absorb vitamin D.
But MK4 is the necessary vitamin K component to get calcium into the bone.
And it's just not in any supplements and you need to have this dose.
So three a day gives you 22,500 micrograms of vitamin K2 in the form of MK4.
And if you don't get MK4, you're never going to get calcium into the bone.
And your body will convert some MK7 to MK4.
So if you are taking it or getting it in your food, you'll get a little teeny bit, but nothing like this dose.
And it's going to be harder to heal your bones.
So this is three capsules a day.
I said four capsules a day, but I'd say three to four capsules a day.
If you're trying to heal bones, you could go up to maybe five, but I wouldn't go more than that.
You don't need any more than 500 milligrams of calcium.
Getting any more calcium to this without getting MK4 is actually at a risk.
Because if you get more calcium without the MK4, and this is just, calcium is just circulating in your blood.
And it has the potentiality of blocking your blood vessels.
It has the potentiality of binding to cholesterol in your walls of your arteries.
So you have to have MK4.
So the history of women take, oh, you have osteoporosis need to be on 1500 milligrams of calcium.
Was just the most horrific advice given to man because all these women in their heart.
Remember, women's heart disease in the 1970s was like one fifth that of men's heart disease.
And now it's almost equal.
Well, it's because of the use of calcium without using MK4.
So you need to use calcium, but at a lower dose, never 1500 milligrams, never.
And you have to be taking MK4 at this kind of dose.
And I have not found any other supplement that has, there's not another one on the market that I found that has this, except this company.
That's not even all that expensive. It's 70 bucks.
So that's the only way to go for osteoporosis, bone loss, try to build bone strength and prevent bone loss.
Now, if you don't have any history of osteoporosis, or you just have been told that you have osteopaedia,
or you don't have any history of bone metastasis, then you only need to take one of these a day.
But this is what to take.